[Music]
leaders
bring out the best in us doing a nice
pay for the site for
nico two shots and two kills oh need go
they push us beyond our limits isolate
our strengths and refine
our weaknesses spotted out long range
tap gets the head shot now
on the other side oh my god leaders show
up when the odds aren't in our favor
when it feels like all hope is lost gets
to the ak quickly without response he's
in a great position and nico's got all
three
they redefine what loyalty means they
stick it out while their surroundings
change
and they understand what it means to
play
as a team my goals at the moment are
that we become the best team in the
world
this is the story of leadership the
story of perseverance
and eventual dominance the story of
becoming the best in the world
at what you do this is the story
of nico
[Music]
and nico lands the final nail in the
coffin
nicola nico kovach was born on february
16
1997 in bosnia and was first exposed to
counter-strike as a nine-year-old
when his parents introduced him to net
cafes
from the very beginning counter-strike
for nico was about getting better than
those around him
from besting his peers then building a
team of locals and finally in 2013
joining pro counter-strike teams i
nation and later
team refuse nice shot and ynk does shut
him down but right now nico pushing into
the site will be able to pick up any
kills here as he does see mahdi gets him
down
early on in his career nico primarily
played with serbian rosters and was
focused on elevating his region
to reach counter-strike relevancy in
fact he wanted to be great with a
regional roster so badly
that he declined an offer to join mouse
sports
when i was turning 18 i got my first
offer for mousesports which i declined
i still believe that i can make it to
the top with my serbian team
i did not tell to my parents because i
knew that they would force me to
to accept the offer because they knew
that i wanted this since i was a kid
but despite playing on a number of
different rosters he was never able to
find the level of success he craved
he knew he wanted to be the best and
quickly realized
that he couldn't do that in bosnia so
after two years of playing competitively
with regional rosters
nico accepted a second offer from mouse
on march 4th
2015. now they enter esl one cologne
with the biggest gun of them all
boasting the mighty nico considered by
some to be the best player
in counter-strike during his transition
to mouse nico was known as a promising
young talent
and garnered a reputation as the
region's top prospect
keeping it up here he's going to get a
fourth one is he able to get the ace he
wants to go for you can see him slowly
creeping out he's gonna pick up the ak
gets smoked out but he keeps charging
and he does get the ace against virtus
pro
so that's got to put a smile on his face
so guys five kill around from him
mouse was largely in a developmental
phase during nico's first year
and the team lacked the firepower
necessary to compete with the best
but nico was proving that he was more
than capable of rifling with the scenes
best
and as we've come to learn the bosnian
marksman had an extraordinary ability to
secure frags with a deagle
or just about any other weapon this is
by is going to be torn away from them
very very quickly by scientists oh my
god
three four oh my lungs i don't believe
it
and what on earth has just happened is
deagle is on fire and sharks is gonna
walk into it as well nico
is on fire five in an effort to shake up
their lineup
mouse dropped gob b in december of 2015
the team's primary shot caller which
placed a metaphorical captain's crest on
nico's chest
heading into the new year and the next
era of mousesports
just nico things right now as the attack
comes back in body with a frag nico with
the spray down though one more player to
find 18 health to do it with asami goes
through the smoke he sees the legs
and nico with an amazing quad kill there
and as january came around
most sports were more or less the nico
show with the aniko on the outside he
gets the one kill comes back from the
noise phrase he wins one more there's
still the using
nico he's gonna go for it he's gonna try
to get the quad kill oh my god
nico but while nico continued to wow the
cs go community
mouse were still a middle of the pack
team g2 they're all unattended so
there's only two left here for mouse
plus to try to make this fight take
they're gonna get completely annihilated
and there it is during the beginning of
their 2016 campaign they finished fifth
sixth at dreamhack open leipzig
won acer predator masters season 2
placed 9th 12th at the mlg major in
columbus
and 8th at esl pro league europe season
3.
even throughout their flashes of
brilliance it was always nico
clutching the round nico stealing the
show
and nico dragging his teammates up the
treacherous side
of the pro cs go mountain here but
niko's gonna shut down one player two
and then three
without eagle what an earth is just
happened there nico
delivering massively for mouse sports
mouse were able to qualify for 2016's
second major
esl one cologne but they walked away
with a mediocre
9th 12th finish during the event nico
finished with a 1.07 rating
and 71 total kills but again
fell short of adding a significant
finish to his resume
with that said the team did rebound from
cologne nicely
putting up their most notable finish to
date with nico on the roster
a semi-final exit from e-league season
one
it looked like it was gonna be different
on the second map but certainly
as long as mouse sports were playing on
the terrorist side they were putting up
a lot of fight
ct side they just cannot do it through
esl one cologne and e-league season one
the cs world had more or less come to a
consensus that
nico was among the world's greatest
counter-strike players
but he was playing on a team that was
struggling to hang on to a top 10
ranking
he's one of the best players in the
world he's got unbelievable aim and
probably a really good game sense as
well
but nico didn't want to go anywhere
something that has since become a
fixture of his identity as a pro player
unlike other star players who are
willing to jump ship to chase wins
nico has always tried to bring his team
up to his level
not abandon them nico has always been
team
first you know everyone can say like
you're the best player or whatever your
team's getting better but
you have to get to that level sooner so
when should it happen now
when is the point when massage has to
perform i think that now it's a league
and the major that
i feel like that we have to go through
the rules to advance the playoffs and
see what we can do there
throughout the remainder of 2016 nico
continued to shine bright
as the game's most feared player but
mouse maintained their mediocrity
they finished third fourth at esl pro
league season four finals
and then fifth eighth at e-league season
two
optic gaming move past mousesports who
are gonna be
out of the tournament the green wall
persists
as the calendar turned and 2017 began
all eyes were on nico at the eleague
major atlanta
the community had agreed that it was
time for the world's best player
to add some much deserved hardware to
his trophy case
if nico could fight his way out mouse
had a chance
but not even the best in the game could
carry his team out of the hole they dug
him into
i think all of a sudden you have a
situation where nothing just seems to be
going right for nico and i think now
we're starting to see him kind of like
buckle under all the pressure having to
be the star player at points having to
be the in-game leader
to say that e-league atlanta was a
disappointment would be a dramatic
understatement mouse finished 12th 14th
and didn't make it past the group stage
absolutely heartbreaking
they end up on nuke and they did not
look like a team that were prepared for
it
at all now that's one of the more
devastating losses that we've seen here
obviously it's devastating you've lost
you you're out of the tournament but i
don't think that anybody on mousesports
can say that they performed up to the
level that they needed like that
and probably that they thought that they
could bring on new
it was clear that the bosnian superstar
needed to make a change to live up to
his immense potential
and on february 9 2017
nico left mousesports despite his desire
to stick it out with mouse
nico packed his bags and left for faze
clan
a move that was nothing short of a
blockbuster signing
well speaking of leaving the team as you
just mentioned you will be joining faze
after this event
uh how excited are you and what are your
expectations joining this new team
i'm really looking forward to this it's
been a long time since i
wanted to play with them like maybe
especially with train because i really
like that player
so i don't know i think that our goals
is gonna be like to reach top one i
think and that's it faze already had its
star power in kerrigan and mixing
superstars
in pro cs was and still is a big risk
but as we know now faze and nico were
the perfect match
but now with the most recent edition of
nico they're actually looking like a
team
who can be a contender for championships
moving into the future
nico kiyoshima aloo karrigan and reign
began their journey together with their
first premier event
at starladder season three and they made
their presence felt
immediately two of us is full making it
into a one-on-four here as cole picks up
the killer brain with a headshot and
that's it
16-7 as faze knock sk
out of the tournament eliminating them
and moving on themselves
faze clan defeated the likes of sk
gaming g2 esports and hellraisers to
find themselves in the finals
their first big splash with nico on the
roster smoke goes all the way to work
coffins as well miss shot on the first
stop does then two though nico
makes up for it they jump above the
scope it'll take him down
but he had to hit two faze met astralis
in the grand final
and it was time that nico showed the
world he could perform
when there was some hardware on the line
though flashed off good timing on that
flash
molotov goes in carby manages the
crossfire with dupreeh he's gone though
and there's a lot of players trying to
push krb's position inside a pin
successful
is nico crowds loving it for faze
nico the addition kerrigan the in-game
leader they finally look more tame what
a shot though from zippex
he'll go on to the ak the device needs
to be
extremely good on the way through knows
one's in the corner hits it
incredible but no way it's done they
take down devices typics is found and
faze clan
with all the tools will extinguish
the chances of astralis to repeat and
they go 1-1 and finals
and get their revenge killing is going
to love it nico's gonna lead the way
it's phase the win in starladder
nico had finally landed somewhere where
the supporting cast wasn't blinded by
him being the game's brightest star
now with winning on their mind nico and
faze clan
had their eyes set on a major title
but krakow wasn't the place for nico's
destiny to be realized
faze clan didn't even make it out of
groups and even worse
they were bested by nico's former team
mousesports
that has to be highest expectation and
worst outcome that i've seen
in recent memory as a major the
community had high hopes for fays to
make a run
and prove themselves in krakow but they
still had a long way to go
russian taps and waits at emo good time
on the peak good damage
they're lining up for making it a lot
easier as well as he goes to the pistol
and a crossfire
established 13 rounds for big no
terrorist rounds won yet by phase as
five have gone by in the way of the cts
they were close but something else
needed to change
in order for them to reach the upper
echelon of cs go
and what happened next blew the lid off
the counter-strike scene
guardian has joined faze replacing alu
when you consider this is a super team
that even in the context of super teams
is incredibly stacked i mean they have
three players
who you could make a case at one point
in history were legitimately the best
player in the world they have nico
they have olive meister they have
guardian in the weeks following the
krakow major
faze clan acquired olofmeister and
guardian two of the best players
in the world these two stars in
conjunction with nico kerrigan and reign
became the newest iteration of faze clan
and nico
was the team's linchpin if phase run is
the problem i would just look towards
negro and he'll probably close it down
for him
now this new phase roster would be a
test for nico
the traditional idea of leadership that
he exemplified with mouse
couldn't exist while surrounded by
superstars
all egos would have to be pushed aside
and nico
would have to focus on being the young
gun instead of the team captain
for the first time this super team
iteration of faze clan
had only a handful of premier events to
prove themselves before the next major
including esl one new york and the 2017
e-league premiere in atlanta faze clan
came just unleashes fury glaive is there
though oh
nico needs to be absolutely precise and
he is that's nico
they saw don't let me get it
oh my god what has happened rain
had long looking for blood and he gets
four headshots it's over the refs called
it
and they conquered kerrigan dies in the
last rounds
so to see
[Applause]
not only did they win both events but
they made it look
easy sure the squad was filled with an
obnoxious amount of talent
but what was most impressive was their
ability to play as a cohesive team
attention away there together in the
long range awp carrigan with a headshot
guardian again
and nico shutting it down nothing that
australis can do
15 rounds the pressure never rested on
just one player's shoulders
and the team wasn't dragged kicking and
screaming to glory
by a single competitor everyone had one
goal in mind
securing trophies and that goal was
realized in back-to-back events
just an incredible performance this team
is not really that old they just formed
it and
usually takes a while before you get to
this level not in this case
[Applause]
[Music]
to say that nico was an integral part to
the team's rise to the top
would be an understatement he sacrificed
his frags
his stardom and his stats for the better
of the team
and set a new benchmark for what it
means to be a leader
and it's here where nico separates
himself from the pack
while other superstars like simple have
been mired by instability
and claims of toxicity nico keeps quiet
his numbers aren't those of a hard carry
and they may not always jump off the
page at first glance
but the winds pile up all the same
the stage was set for the pinnacle of
nico's career to be reached
faze clan were the overwhelming
favorites to win
the boston major anything less than
first place
was simply a failure faze went three and
one at the new challenger stage with
significant wins against both natice
vincere and team liquid
then they swept their way through the
new legend stage beating fnatic
vega squadron and the almighty sk gaming
time is running out what a game it's
been 16-12
phase made their way to the playoffs yet
again in a major tournament
faze clan were meeting expectations and
the new champion stage
was set first up was a revamped version
of nico's former team
this time though the bosnian got the
better of mouse sports
here we go then it's nico coming in the
back lines takes down chris j
all of a sudden it's flipped around once
again two versus one the world's best
player up against it the stay
in the game they'll go for the fake
gamefuse but nico not taking the bait
can we finish this job yes he can we're
going all over time
oh my god next faze met simple and natus
vincere in the semi-finals
a team of superstars against one of the
scene's deadliest players
likely i should say what a shot from
guardian words out of my mouth as he
nails it through the box he is tagged up
smoking the bomb immediately he's got
the kit doesn't elect to hold on to
again he's got
time to play with one and two for two
smoke will do
it's phased to the final and guardian is
an absolute god
not only did faze put up another 2-0
sweep but nico
popped off he finished with a plus 20
over the two games
and a 1.51 rating nico's eyes were now
set on the game's top prize
ladies and gentlemen welcome to the
e-league major
boston
the stage was set for a david versus
goliath-esque finals
as faze clan's super team were set to
take on a young cloud 9 squad
that were hungry to become the first
north american counter-strike franchise
to win a major across the shore that's
information they know and say oh
nico goes down straight away that was
maybe the only chance but guardian comes
back in
oh god if he gets two there's still more
to go though cowboy must pop the bomb
the peaks come in the guardian
will not stop one more to go and
guardian
gets them all the very closer
destination
olive meister with the off angle and it
seems to be nothing the cloud9 can do
running up to short position i think all
of might have hurt him
which means that they can all hold
angles the smoke fake
the flashback won't work out face plan
take the first map of this series
look at the timing absolutely perfect
but look this is his map after
all he has 30 hp he's got no grenades
he's holding a tight angle
guardian is so red not expecting it it's
good doodle that's one more to find
it's going to look good nuclear four
kills for him
wait patiently
[Applause]
the series went to a game three inferno
for a major title i can't wait to see
what these teams have to offer us here
on inferno face clan on the ct side
cloud nine will start as they mean to go
on
as the aggressors boston makes a noise
c9 were playing out of their minds and
early in game three
faze were having trouble keeping up with
what's buffing he hears the rotation he
punishes it immediately
a fatal mistake from faze cloud9 are
harvesting eyeballs and organs
and look at this a late retake here from
cloud nine the flashes are in
so he goes in front nico gets two and
that is huge
as with many great stories of
competition this one
went into overtime nothing else is going
on he's gotta go back
stewie's on his own but look at the time
look at the time there's seven seconds
of nothing
they're trying to build pyramids but
there's no more play
stewie's running around we're going to
overtime going inside
[Applause]
in overtime cloud9 made it clear that
they were not going to lay down and let
faze clan complete
a comeback victory c9 took the first
three rounds
to open up an 18-15 lead i don't know
how he's done this
another challenge that's all he has to
win out but he can't it's tarik
tarik all the way three rounds in a row
but faze responded rattling off four of
their own round wins consecutively
two on two now and it's taric he's got
higher health but it's not perfect
down he goes it's guardian he's the only
man standing between cloud nine
and the major it's gonna be a double p
then the first one
we're going to overtime number two
cloud9 don't do it they're still in this
major faith plan
and then heartbreak it's guardian versus
two
can he do it again he's in this position
before to win phase
around a very important very crucial one
can he deny cloud9
we saw it from this position before he
cannot
miss a single shot guardian waits
patiently as cloud9 sets the push up oh
oh it's happened they made it work
clown nine are your league major
champions
[Applause]
this has to be one of the most
incredible story lines
we've ever had it could hardly have been
more difficult
they weren't the favorites they were the
underdogs they were a heavy underdog
but they did it for north america
in the wake of landing on the
unfortunate side of cloud9's historic
run
faze clan has more or less maintained
their stranglehold as one of the best
teams
in the game nico is still considered one
of the best players in the game
alongside the likes of simple and
coldzera and this still may be the most
intimidating roster in the game's
history
but as with anything in esports things
are constantly in flux
olofmeister had taken a series of breaks
from competitive play
returning to phase full time in july
astralis meanwhile
had taken over the throne as the number
one ranked team in the world
with simple and navi nipping at their
heels but
even though faze aren't untouchable
they've still proven to be the same
lethal force when their stars align even
without olofmeister at esl one bello
horizonte
nico and company were able to take the
first place prize
sending a message to the rest of the
community that they were nothing to
scoff at when major season
comes back around he's got to pinch it
in there
he's out of ammo they know it till they
get on the defuse
he's just barely done it as he oh my god
it's so close
things get away with it
[Applause]
oh my god no bullets and somehow they
get away
as the face at london major loomed in
late september 2018
olaf returned to faze clan and nico and
company had another shot
to make history with their hopes for
major glory in the balance
faze tripped out of the gate with an o2
start in the group stage
quiet but it doesn't matter because the
game going in favor of navi shortly olaf
versus four
electronic to close him down 16 12 navi
go one and one
they're back on level footing and in a
good position in the tournament however
phase
or owen two facing elimination not at
all where you would have expected a team
of that pedigree this early on
but as we know champions don't quit when
the odds are against them
16 to 2 phase utterly dominates
g2 they never sort of chance it would
seem it didn't really offer up all that
much here in this
game of mirage james nico and faze clan
rallied off three consecutive victories
to find themselves qualified for the
elimination rounds
in the quarterfinals faze would face
maybe their toughest challenge
since boston astralis the world's top
ranked team
ladies and gentlemen bring the noise for
astralis
and the faze clan
the match was a war he's gonna tap the
bomb just holding it down all of waiting
on the other side one more second
and graphics gonna get the shot and he
should have the time as well for the
defuse
a one-on-two early on to get astralis on
the board
that is just very difficult to do meg is
sneaking down the timing is god like
and he's gonna complete that he might
wrap around him put up a grenade as the
ump comes through kerrigan going to be
picking up and killed the bomb down 30
seconds and he finishes it off that is
really well done it's rain not easy to
put him out of a round he's gonna get
that first kill and he's just hiding and
waiting
they line up for a great triple spray
down just gonna continue into the quad
they're taking down the three and they
line up for a beautiful spray nico
dropping both
through banana sip has got no chance at
all he's still getting a double oh my
god
the ump a triple you guys gonna smoke it
off down on the low ground tapping the
bomb and he goes down
second kill for all of they keep it
alive this is going to be inside the
ball side
the off might be a tough crossfire they
lose the first they're gonna lose so
much more
they're gonna lose it all no chance here
rain and guardian left two on four and
you're absolutely right moses there's
nothing left to fight for cardi with the
mac 10.
he chases down one but it's 16 12 and
astralis make another semi-final
here at the major another chance to seal
the letter
on a storied career and another bracket
exit
from staying loyal in bosnia to trying
to make it work with mousesports and
coming so close
with faze clan nico has become a
household name
in the cs go scene there aren't that
many win-loss metrics that separate the
best players in counter-strike
but above all else the ability to take
home that major trophy
can make or break the legacy of a career
and
for someone as bent on greatness as nico
is nothing short
of a major winning moment will do i
really love what i'm doing and
i'm gonna try to play as long as i can i
don't know what my family will say at
the end of my career
but i believe that they're gonna be
really proud to prove
what it means to be the best in the game
that it takes loyalty
teamwork and sacrifice the things he's
branded himself on
the consummate professional the leader
the captain
the superstar nico
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button